UNCLE JOE, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
DO YOU FIND YOURSELF UP AT NIGHT
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT FOREIGN
POLICY ELITES THINK OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
AND DO YOU REALLY CARE IF
ANGELA MERKEL DOESN'T LIKE TRUMP
OR ANY OF HIS POLICIES?
I DIDN'T THINK SO.
AND YET TODAY'S "POLITICO"
HEADLINE WAS WORLD LEADERS TELL
BIDEN "WE NEED YOU."
"THE    "THE HILL" PICKED UP WHE
"POLITICO" LEFT OFF, GLOBAL
LEADERS URGING BIDEN TO ENTER
2020 RACE.
MY FIRST THOUGHT WAS, WAIT A
SECOND, WHY ARE WE CELEBRATING
FOREIGN COUNTRIES MEDDLING IN
U.S. ELECTIONS?
I THOUGHT FOREIGN POWERS USING
INFLUENCE TO AFFECT OUR VOTE,
ARE CANDIDATES, WAS A BAD THING.
HUH.
WITH THOSE URGING BIDEN TO RUN,
THEY STARTED OUT LAST MONTH'S
MUNICH SECURITY CONFERENCE.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> DID YOU HAVE A CARD?
YOU CAN GET ME THROUGH, I DON'T
HAVE A CARD.
>> Laura: WELL, BIDEN OFFERED
THIS CRYPTIC LINE TO THE
ASSEMBLED CROWD.
>> I PROMISE YOU, I PROMISE YOU,
AS MY MOTHER WOULD SAY, THIS TOO
SHALL PASS.
WE WILL BE BACK.
DON'T HAVE ANY DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THEY ARE GETTING
READY FOR THE WINE CELLARS AT
THE E.U. AGAIN.
BIDEN HAS PASSED HIMSELF ON    O
BIDEN HAS PASSED HIMSELF ON    F
BIDEN HAS PASSED HIMSELF ON    A
BIDEN HAS PASSED HIMSELF ON    S
A FOREIGN POLICY EXPERT.
I GUESS COMPARED TO CORY BOOKER
AND KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND AND BETO,
HE HAS SOME EXPERIENCE IN
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS HE SERVED
EIGHT YEARS IN AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT WAS MARKED BY ONE FOREIGN
POLICY FAILURE AFTER ANOTHER.
THIS IS SUMMED UP REALLY WELL IN
A PIECE ON FOREIGN POLICY WITH
THIS TITLE "JOAD    JOE BIDEN: F
THIS TITLE "JOAD    JOE BIDEN: R
THIS TITLE "JOAD    JOE BIDEN: I
THIS TITLE "JOAD    JOE BIDEN: N
POLICY."
HE HAD WRITTEN A PIECE CLAIMING
THAT WE ARE STRONGER AND MORE
SECURE TODAY THAN WHEN
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AND I
TOOK OFFICE IN JANUARY 2009.
IT IS A TOTAL DELUSION.
LET'S DO A QUICK REVIEW, SHALL
WE?
NUMBER ONE, BIDEN SUPPORT FOR
THE HIDEOUS IRAN DEAL.
>> IF WE CAN TAKE THE NUCLEAR
BOMB OFF THE TABLE, IT IS BETTER
DEALING WITH THOSE BAD GUYS THEN
DEALING WITH THE BAD GUYS AND
THE NUCLEAR BOMB.
THIS IS A GOOD DEAL, FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR THE UNITED STATES,
IT IS A GOOD DEAL FOR THE WORLD,
THE REGION, AND A GOOD DEAL FOR
ISRAEL.
>> Laura: WHO THOUGHT THIS
COULD REPRESENT A NUCLEAR WEAPO
WEAPON?
WELL, IT WAS A HORRIBLE DEAL.
BUT ONE THAT EUROPE LOVED
BECAUSE COUNTRIES LIKE FRANCE
WANTED TO KEEP MAKING MONEY
DOING BUSINESS WITH THE MULLAHS.
IT WAS SHAMEFUL.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE PALACE OF
CASH, $400 MILLION, THAT WAS
ALSO SENT TO IRAN IN THE DEAD OF
NIGHT.
NUMBER TWO FAILURE, THE RISE OF
ISIS UNDER OBAMA AND BIDEN, AS
UNCLE JOE DEFENDED, BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, OBAMA IS FARMING OF
THOSE SYRIAN REBELS.
>> WE ARE WORKING HAND IN GLOVE
WITH TURKS, THE JORDANIANS, THE
SAUDIS, AND WITH ALL OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE REGION, ATTEMPTING
TO IDENTIFY THE PEOPLE WHO
DESERVE THE HELP, SO THAT WHEN
ASSAD GOES, AND HE WILL GO,
THERE WILL BE A LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENT THAT FOLLOWS ON.
NOT AN AL QAEDA SPONSORED
>> Laura: ONE PROBLEM, THE
WEAPONS WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO
ISLAMIC JIHADIST.
GOLD STAR, JOE.
NUMBER THREE FAILURE, THE RISE
OF CHINA ACCELERATED UNDER OBAMA
AND BIDEN.
CHINA'S AGGRESSION STRETCHED TO
THE SOUTH CHINA SEA, STEALING
U.S. AND ELECTORAL PROPERTY,
WENT VIRTUALLY UNCHECKED AND
UNCHALLENGED BY THE OBAMA AND
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET, BENGHAZI,
AND THE FALL OF LIBYA.
A TOTAL DISASTER, AND A TRAGEDY.
WE LOST THE U.S. AMBASSADOR,
THREE FINE AMERICANS, AND THEN,
THE OBAMA-BIDEN CREW LIED ABOUT
THE REASON FOR THE ATTACK AT THE
TIME ROMNEY WAS NIPPING AT THEIR
HEELS IN 2012.
REMEMBER, THAT WAS
SEPTEMBER /OCTOBER, 2012.
AND FINALLY, THE FAILED RUSSIAN
RESET.
RUSSIA'S ANNEXATION OF CRIMEA,
IT'S MOVED TO EASTERN UKRAINE,
WHICH GAVE LENDER PUT IN POWER,
AND A MUCH-NEEDED FOREIGN POLICY
WIN.
I COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON.
OBAMA AND BIDEN FULLY EMBRACE
THIS NEW WORLD ORDER, AND THEY
WERE LOVED BECAUSE THEY EMBRACED
AGREEMENTS LIKE THE
TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP AND
THE U.N. CLIMATE ACCORDS.
TRUMP COMES IN AND REJECTS BOTH.
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES, RIGHTLY,
THEY CEDED TO WATCH AMERICAN
POWER AND DECISION-MAKING TOO
FAR-41 FOREIGN BUREAUCRACY.
BUT BIDEN, OH, HE WOULD RETURN
THINGS TO THE OLD STATUS QUO.
>> THE TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP
IS ANOTHER DISASTER.
DONE AND PUSHED BY SPECIAL
INTERESTS WHO WANT TO RAPE OUR
COUNTRY, EXPECT OTHER COUNTRIES
TO PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE FOR THE
COST OF THEIR DEFENSE.
AMERICANS WILL BE THE CAPTAINS
OF THEIR OWN DESTINY ONCE AGAIN.
>> Laura: TRUMP ACTUALLY GOES
TO BRUSSELS AND HE DECLARES THAT
THE ERA OF FREE WRITING FROM
NATO IS OVER, THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER IS FED UP, AND THE
FOREIGN POLICY ELITES GATHERED,
JUST BRISTLED.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
WELL, HE DID.
OUR ECONOMY IS THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD.
THEIR ECONOMIES, IN MANY CASES
FALTERING AFTER DECADES OF
SOCIAL WELFARE SPENDING AND HIGH
TAXES.
SO OF COURSE, THE OLD EURO
ELITES, THEY WANT TO TURN TO THE
STATUS QUO WHEN THEY HAD ALL OF
THE POWER, AND LET'S FACE IT,
NOTHING SAYS STATUS QUO MORE
THAN AMTRAK JOE.
HE IS THE FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT.
AND EVEN MEMBERS OF THAT CLUB,
THEY SAY BIDEN WAS A DISASTER,
LIKE FORMER OBAMA DEFENSE
SECRETARY BOB GATES.
WHO WROTE IN HIS MEMOIR "BIDEN
HAS BEEN WRONG ON NEARLY EVERY
MAJOR FOREIGN         FOREIGN PL
MAJOR FOREIGN         FOREIGN PC
MAJOR FOREIGN         FOREIGN PY
MAJOR FOREIGN         FOREIGN PA
MAJOR FOREIGN         FOREIGN PD
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE OVER THE
PAST FOUR DECADES."
OUCH.
OH, BUT NONE OF THAT MATTERS.
COUNCIL ON FOREIGN RELATIONS
HERE, OR PROGRESSIVE EUROPEAN
OFFICIALS ABROAD.
SPAIN'S FORMER FOREIGN MINISTER
GAVE IT ALL THE WAY IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH "POLITICO," BIDEN
IS "DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THE
TRANSATLANTIC COMMUNITY AND THE
RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL
ORDER."
HERE'S A TRANSLATION, OKAY?
COMMITTED TO EMPOWERING THE
GLOBAL ELITES AND SWOLLEN GLOBAL
BUREAUCRACY IS WHO MADE THE
RULES AND SET THE PRIORITIES FOR
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YAY.
NO.
BUT ONLY 5% OF AMERICAN VOTERS
FOCUS ON FOREIGN POLICY OR
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES.
I WOULD EXPECT THE ELECTORATE
WILL FOCUS ON POCKETBOOK ISSUES